pas question de reculer devant le
cimetière Notre-Dame des Neiges à
Montréal des dizaines de personnes se
faufilent à travers la clôture force
parfois même les barreaux pour se rendre
jusqu'à la tombe de leur mère ils
empruntent ce chemin inhabituel en
colère parce que l'accès à certaines
parties du cimetière est barrée pensez
pas qui ouvre seulement la porte du fond
je pensais qu'il allait ouvrir ici c'est
ridicule
totalement de respect pour les défunts
qui sont là je trouve ça dégueulasse
parce que ça coûte cher et ça nous coûte
extrêmement cher puis on a pas de
service le quartier est complètement
congestionné des centaines de familles
se mastent vers la seule porte ouverte
du cimetière en ce jour de la fête des
mères à l'entrée principale le directeur
les accueille mais il reçoit une pluie
de reproches
mais faites quelque chose à cause d'une
grève du personnel d'entretien le
cimetière est complètement fermé depuis
janvier l'absence des effectifs retard
de son ouverture officielle car le
verglas a fait d'importants dégâts
combien de temps ça va prendre je sais
qu'on va mettre les énergies puis
évidemment si la discussion se conclue
avec nos syndicats sont en grève mais ça
va faire de la main de additionnel pour
aider à se nettoyage là on a tout essayé
pour éviter ça puis le but c'est de
négocier puis c'est encore ça on
travaille avec le conciliateur en ce
moment on veut retourner travailler mais
le ministre du travail commence aussi à
en avoir assez ce conflit de travail dur
depuis trop longtemps il est temps que
cela se règle je m'attende dit j'en
voulais à des développements la semaine
prochaine c'est le souhait que partage
aussi cette mère en deuillée car depuis
des mois ces portes fermées l'empêche de
se recueillir sur la tombe de son fils
c'est difficile pour perder un enfant
mais si tu n'es pas capable pour aller
pour visite
c'est plus difficile ici Charles
Dumoulin Radio-Canada Montréal